mieux aux français 3 rosemont on le
connaissait patron de seat politiques
publiques et le voilà en selle pour 2021
candidat j
une candidature qui s'appuie sur les
ateliers de cherchell c'est une
association citoyenne de celle chez moi
ils nous expliquent qu'ils ont fait un
diagnostic de leur ville de ce
diagnostic est sorti une boîte à outils
pour faire de la ville un endroit dont
il rêve
nous ne savons pas ici d'une amie nous
ment du pays
cette nouvelle version est jeune je
souffrais au sacrifice
je veux aussi une concision citoyenneté
puissance est soumis un projet municipal
bâtissions aux ambitions tel est le
programme des ateliers shanxi roi avec
la création de conseils de quartier pour
faire vivre une démocratie participative
la mise en place d'un plan
d'accessibilité dans les bâtiments
publics pour les handicapés ou les
personnes fragiles sans oublier un
chantier important améliorer la
situation du personnel municipal
mais pendant toute cette présentation
qui a duré deux heures aucune critique à
l'encontre de l'équipe municipale en
place qui vont pas dans une
conflits de personne nous portons un
projet nous consommerons un projet avec
les habitants de celle cher et ça nous
paraît suffisant pour les séduire et les
convaincre
voilà c'est un vrai projet d'importance
un vrai projet citoyen c'est vrai projet
de société pour celle cher et nous
espérons que les chefs chinois nous font
confiance
faire schelcher ensemble ça sera
peut-être le slogan de cette liste à un
an des municipales
franck sainte-rose rosemont est le
premier à avoir déclaré officiellement
sa candidature à schoelcher
[Applaudissements]